it's December time can you believe it's
December already you know what this
month I'm not doing any training and
he's speaking I'm not going to any
events but what I am doing is I am
finding deals the reason is is because
most people they don't invest in
December because December is Christmas
time people are relaxed they're spending
time with the family they're waiting to
set their new resolutions for next year
and that creates a lot of opportunity so
check this video out to see why and I'll
let you know how many we're doing this
month and how you can have a very
prosperous December
[Music]
so I'm currently on paternity which
means that I'm not really working
the reason I'm speaking so quietly is
because my six week old baby girl has
just fallen asleep to be honest I'm not
really feeling in the mindset and in the
mode of putting a suit on and going out
and meeting in a boardroom I would much
rather just stay at home with my
beautiful wife and baby girl but here's
the thing
Christmastime December I believe is
probably the best month to invest in
property okie-dokie see yeah one of the
things you'll realize about properties
that the rules are always changing but
as long as you've got researchers
looking into it and you're keeping on
top of things you'll always be able to
stay ahead of the game in property which
is really important to do so here I'm
just pulled up at the car park so
looking forward to catching up with the
guys see how they're getting on and some
of you might think I saw you cause you
don't actually have to go out and view
the properties and source them because
you've got a team of sources that do
that for you but the fingers you can use
the same sources are you you know the
guys my guys whose source for me they
also source for the public as well
public investors so for anybody so that
really is an excuse if you have a lot of
time physically to go you are gonna need
time to fill out the paperwork speak to
the mortgage broker which people just
don't want to do in December but you
don't actually have to just look at the
properties yourself
Samuel leads headquarters but here we
are beautiful
[Music]
Hey how's it good guys you've got some
really good houses to look at haven't
you thank you
also Chris our project manager tell us
about the new changes that are coming in
for HMOs in April we've been under local
authorities around the country one of
the major changes up north is if now if
you have five people over three floors
it would license it yes mmm
you wouldn't over two floors in the
future it doesn't matter how many floors
you have you're gonna have to license it
you've got five people in that growing
yes now it's not gonna affect us too
much though is it and why is that it's
not gonna affect us because we are
trying to create properties that are
ready for licensing if it comes up yes
it's good to think ahead we do a lot of
our due diligence a lot of people do you
think that in a four-bed HMO that it's
okay to not have fires and smoke alarms
only so basically if they do change the
rules which they probably will our house
is a little bit well anyway through the
door we're happy yes so so Elliott says
the clinic properties that you've been
sourcing for me over the last couple of
days Grimsby of course is just not
working phenomenally well we've just
learned this spending a hundred million
over the next ten years and so goobies
working really really well Paul we've
spent a lot of time in halls and good
pops up in Hall Middlesbrough middles
was phenomenal with the the University
there so vendors are pretty motivated at
this time of year absolutely they want
to be sold before Christmas excellent
well thank you so much guys I'll let you
crack on with your day and I'll see you
very soon see whether yeah so there we
have it a fantastic session with the
guys they've got some really good houses
coming up is what happens in December
one then does get very motivated because
they want to sell their house before
Christmas to investors get very lazy
because they feel Chris Messina wanting
to wind down which equals in three all
the best deals are left for me at
Christmas time so I'm gonna have a good
Christmas this year
you are to don't wait until January to
get one more house in the bag
see you Sunday bye hope you found that
video useful inspirational and helpful
for more videos like this please don't
forget to subscribe right here below and
I look forward to seeing you very soon
[Music]